welcome back to my series of pre-1970s
reviews were getting closer to the end
of the year we've done one every single
month and this month we're gonna be
talking about peeping tom a film
directed by British filmmaker Michael
Powell director of such films as a
matter of life and death or the red
shoes he was Oscar nominated for Best
Writing for one of our aircraft is
missing and then in 1960 he released a
little film called peeping tom a film
that showed the point of view of a
killer as he stopped his female victims
it received a critical mauling did
horribly at the box office was barely
released in the States until many years
later and effectively destroyed Michael
Powell's career but the film maintained
a cult status throughout the 1970s and
eventually gained a lot more popularity
when filmmakers like Martin Scorsese
listed it as one of their favorite films
and later Scorsese helped to actually
re-release the film which got it to an
even wider audience and now today it's
considered a masterpiece of
psychological horror and one of the
earliest slasher films the film follows
a photographer for hire and a focus
puller on Hollywood sets named Mark
Lewis who uses a movie camera to film
women as they die because he has an
obsession with capturing that moment of
fear and he's never able to fully grasp
that moment and he has a bit of a
perverse attraction to fear we learned
throughout the film that he was raised
by a scientist his father studied him
when he was young
often recorded him and tried to frighten
him or recorded him while he watched a
couple kissing in a park his father was
obsessed with capturing those moments
and understanding how fear went through
the body of a child and so naturally he
didn't have the greatest youth and as an
adult now he's inherited some of this
obsession he finds himself as an adult
consumed with a desire to watch other
people we today call that voyeurism and
this film definitely blurs the line
between
what a movie can do as a fictional piece
of art but also introducing what a movie
really does and have that be the main
characters psychosis because we're
following a man who's obsessed with
watching other people and he takes it to
extremes but as fans of movies when we
sit in a theater that's exactly what
we're doing we're watching you know the
fictional sometimes non fictional lives
of other people play out before our eyes
and we are the voice in that situation
and so this movie has a very unique way
of combining similar themes watching art
and living art Roger Ebert talked about
this considerably in his review of the
film where he said the movies make us
into voyeurs we sit in the dark watching
other people's lives it is the bargain
the cinema strikes with us
although most films are too well behaved
to mention it today peeping tom is tame
by comparison to other films we've seen
just from the 1970s alone or later in
the 60s there isn't even any on-screen
violence there's one little moment of
blood but for the most part all of the
violence is implied there is nudity
which today is considered one of the
first instances of full frontal female
nudity in a British film but it's
extremely brief and by again today's
standards tasteful nevertheless this
film still deeply disturbed critics of
1960 and as a result Alfred Hitchcock
chose not to have a press screening of
psycho which obviously is a considerably
more violent film but was still a big
success whereas peeping tom wasn't and
it took many years to receive a critical
reappraisal which today as I have
already said it's considered a horror
masterpiece one of the reasons I wanted
to talk about this movie is because it
does sort of interest me when I think
about just how much power a film critic
actually has over a filmmaker because
those initial critics and the reception
to this film in 1960 kind of tanked
Michael Powell's career even though he
was an Oscar nominee and I've said this
many times in reviews and I'll say it
again being a film critic
is considerably easier than being a
filmmaker the filmmaker has the hard job
the film critic just has to sit there
and watch it it's people like Michael
Powell who decide to make a film like
peeping tom that's totally different and
very subversive and extremely dangerous
and because of films like that we now
today as artists can explore deeper and
darker themes and we have films like
this to thank for it thankfully it's
also a really damn good movie extremely
well directed some of the shots are
actually framed like a photograph the
exploration of this dark and tormented
character portrayed by karl böhm not
sure if i pronounce his name right I
genuinely think this is one of the
greatest performances in film he had
such a difficult job in that he had to
portray someone who up until then in
cinema was always like this man masked
in shadow holding a gun and you're
supposed to hate him he has no
personality and the the murderer is in
no way sympathetic and this film
portrays this character as sympathetic
even though we witness through his POV
the murder of various women and yet the
film depicts him as a bit of an antihero
you're not supposed to look at him and
condone what he's doing but it's most
certainly a portrait of a tortured man
and it's asking you to understand how he
got to that point in his life and we do
because it's just so well told as we
experience scenes where he is showing
this girl that he is starting to fall in
love with who lives beneath him video
from his childhood the mother who was
blind in one of the best scenes in the
film shows up in this studio and
horrifies him when she starts to ask him
all of these very invasive questions and
it's these performances and this dark
portrayal of a sympathetic villain even
though he's our lead that make this film
still effective all these years later
and you can also interpret what he
suffers from in totally different ways
it can be viewed as a sexual problem and
there are certainly hints of that as he
takes his fingers and runs his hands
along the tripod of his camera but it
could also be viewed entirely from the
perspective of mental trauma that this
character just does not know another
form of life because of how he spent his
childhood this is not only a fascinating
film with an incredible lead performance
it's also a fascinating story - how it
came about how film critics of the era
destroyed it and how later film critics
and filmmakers like Martin Scorsese
we're gratefully smart enough to say hey
you guys were wrong this movie is
definitely worth your time and I highly
suggest checking out peeping toms you've
never seen it especially if you're a big
horror fan because it's kind of integral
to the development of horror and cinema
I'm gonna give peeping tom and a guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I wanted to talk about a scary film at
the end of September because we're
getting into October which is my
favorite month of the whole year we're
gonna be talking about a lot of scary
movies next month look forward to that
guys thank you so much for continuing to
watch this series and as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]